I think some of the best conversations that we've had have been the conversations that break down reality from false reality.
In entertainment, you know, you get hit with a false reality that this is your life and this is what it's going to be forever.
Oh my God, you're famous and you make money forever.
That's not the case.
And if you're not a person that can understand that, you get caught up in the matrix.
And when that goes away, you don't know what life is because you fell into the perception that life is this fake fictional presentation.
And it's not. Life changes.
There's ups and downs.
Moments are great and then they're bad.
And entertainment, that's what it is.
So just because we're hot today does not mean we'll be hot tomorrow.
But the smart people that are hot today prepare for the times when they may not be hot.